hey everybody and welcome to a brand
video today I'm going to be talking
about what items I'm going to be
investing the bit in before dragon's
lair 2 comes out so recently I have miss
lickable opportunities for investments
before major updates and I decided maybe
I'd make a video but at this time on the
exact items I'm going to be investing in
the horse these are just guesses they're
really anything can kind of happen but
these are just my assumption for when
the update comes out so I'm gonna be
talking about a few items here to start
off here I am using the G tracker they
are a sponsor of mine for the channel a
very useful tool for checking grant
exchange prices there will be a link in
the description for that ok let's get
started here so my number one pick for
the item I'm going to invest in from the
buy a few these a couple weeks before
the update comes out and that is the
dragon hunter crossbow this is gonna be
for actually a few different reasons so
to start off here at the dragon hunter
crossbow is one of the few weapons that
will be able to fire the new dragon
bolts which is gonna be added with the
Dragon Slayer to update the only other
weapons they'll be able to fire these
bolts I think are the our middle
crossbow and the dragon crossbow which
is coming out with the update so only
two items in the game currently they'd
be able to use it with we just double
checked here can only be fired from the
dragon hunter crossbow the dragon
crossbow and the armadale crossbows so
that's correct only two items in the
game currently they can use it so that
already is a pretty good reason to
invest in this item because a lot of
people are gonna want it for the new
item and that alone is probably why I'm
gonna invest in it but on top of that it
is the dragon hunter crossbow and I
think is also gonna be used to kill the
new dragons so if you don't know Adam
and Dragons are coming into the game and
a lot of people are going to want to use
the most efficient weapon for killing
them I think the dragon hunter crossbow
will be one of them so you can see they
have been rising up for a bit now but I
would expect them to peak even higher
and even go up to someone like 30 mil
maybe before the update drops and
probably the buy three or four of these
guys so for a similar reason the army
lacrosse blow is probably another decent
investment that's for one go for the
dragon hunter crossbow over this but if
you want to diversify a bit the army la
crossbow may go up a bit as well just
because it is one of the few weapons to
be able to use the dragon bolt however I
do feel like the dragon hunter cross
will be a more popular choice just
because of his inherent nature being
better at killing dragons that being
said for other content in the game
that's not just the new content coming
out it's going to be very useful to be
able to fire dragon bolt through
our Mila crossbows and many more people
may purchase these just to try out the
new bolt whether it be God Wars or
whatever they want so I know if you guys
remember when fossil Island came out but
the dig site teleport actually rose up
tremendously especially in the first day
that came out with it went up to about 8
km pretty sure it's not she won in graph
here but I pretty clearly remember it
going up to 7 or 8 K per teleport during
the day that the fossil ion was released
though this probably comes down to the
fact that there was not a closed
teleport to the barge for people who
haven't actually done the quest however
I do feel like a similar thing could
happen with the felted Hills teleport
and if we have a look is actually quite
low right now
so I think this is a probably a safe
investment to buy some felted Hill
teleports before they come out and it
looks like they would actually buy very
quickly
now the reason I'm not 100% sold on this
is because it fell to pill teleport
brings you somewhere around here and
there is actually a fairy ring right
there and what people have done
fairytales part 2 that being said I
don't actually think it's a requirement
for the quest so it is possible that
some people want the felt uphill
teleports next up is the anti fire
potion now the reason I'm bringing this
up is because of the new superior anti
fire potion you'll be able to make this
by using superior dragon bones on an
anti fire potion so I think temporarily
when this update comes out these may
actually spike up in price because
they're not actually traded that much
otherwise I mean a lot more people are
gonna want to make the new potion to
sell however I wouldn't expect the price
to go up very long and it may even end
up plummeting so I wouldn't really say
this is a very safe investment but I
might buy a couple thousand of these or
ten thousand or something just to see
what happens and the last time I wanted
to talk about quickly is actually the
toxic trident now if any of you saw a
friend's recent video on the rune
dragons you may have seen it was
actually using a toxic trident which are
surprising because historically people
mainly used range or melee to kill
dragons however I guess lavage reckons
you did use the toxic trident 4 so it
did seem to be very effective against it
and it looked like it may actually be
one of the better methods to actually
kill them with as for that reason alone
I may actually buy some of these toxic
tridents before it comes out I wouldn't
expect the price to go up a ton with
these ones because they're already
traded quite a bit and used in a lot of
other facets of the game and that's but
it guys are just a couple items I want
to have a look at I'm gonna probably buy
a little bit of everything just to see
what happens
but really mainly I'm gonna be doing the
dragon hunter crossbow alright that is
about it so again just kind of guesswork
really just my own opinions if you have
something to say about this in the
comment section any other ideas or we
can tell me why I'm wrong there's a
hundred reasons why I might be wrong 100
reasons why I might be right leave a
comment down below and I'll see you next
video